und damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es unter
anderem um den schnelleren
braunkohleausstieg im Rheinland die
Stromerzeugung aus Braunkohle soll in
Nordrhein-Westfalen nämlich früher enden
als geplant also nicht erst 2038 sondern
schon Ende März
2030 so möchte es die Bundesregierung
und der zuständige Minister Robert
Habeck ihm zufolge werden so
280 Millionen Tonnen CO2 eingespart wenn
man eben schneller diese Förderung
beendet und um das aber zu beenden um
diesen Vertrag mit den
[Musik]
mit den
kohleverstromungs beendigungsgesetzes
mit den jeweiligen Unternehmen
abzuschließen da fragt er aufgrund des
Kohle
verströmungsbeendigungsgesetzes hier den
Deutschen Bundestag das heißt es wird
unter anderem um diesen früheren
braunkohleausstieg gehen und der
Bundesminister spricht auch als erstes
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir führen
diese Debatte in einer Zeit von
energiepolitischen Widersprüchen
jedenfalls scheint es so zu sein hier in
Deutschland kreist die Debatte ganz
wesentlich um die energiesicherung wie
kommen wir mit einem stabilen System
durch den Winter bzw durch die nächsten
beiden Winter und zeitgleich findet in
Ägypten die Klimakonferenz die Kopf
statt die darauf dringend dass wir
dekabulisieren müssen hier sorgen wir
dafür dass Kohlekraftwerke oder auch
ölkraftwerke zur Verfügung stehen dort
wird darüber gesprochen dass sie
möglichst nicht mehr lange zur Verfügung
stehen heute morgen in der Atomdebatte
ähnliches zu beobachten wir verlängern
eine Technik von der sich Deutschland
entschieden hat dass es sie nicht mehr
will und nicht mehr braucht
gleichzeitig arbeiten wir im Moment mit
Hochdruck daran die erneuerbaren
Energien nach vorne zu bringen die Netze
auszubauen Wind und Solar zum Backbone
der zukünftigen Energiesicherheit des
Landes zu machen beides wiederholt sich
jetzt in dieser Debatte und wird in
einem Gesetz zusammengeführt wir
brauchen in dieser angespannten Lage für
diesen Winter die Kapazitäten auch von
zwei Braunkohlekraftwerken die sonst
Ende dieses Jahres aus dem Betrieb
gegangen werden neurat die und eh
jeweils mit 600 Megawatt
gleichzeitig müssen wir sehen dass wir
die Emissionen die wir möglicherweise
dieses Jahr zu viel in die Atmosphäre
geben möglichst schnell reduzieren und
entsprechend ist der Gegenschuss dass
wir drei jeweils 1.000 Megawatt
Kraftwerke in dem rheinischen
kohle-revier nicht 2038 vom Netz nehmen
sondern 2030 damit lösen wir das
das was als
Widerspruch in dieser widersprüchlichen
Zeit gegeneinander steht in einem Gesetz
auf und schaffen damit beides
Versorgungssicherheit jetzt in der Zeit
der Not und gleichzeitig einen klaren
Schritt Richtung Horizont in der
Perspektive die wir brauchen die wir
auch als Sicherheit für die Zukunft
brauchen denn man muss die Augen schon
sehr fest zuhalten wenn man glaubt dass
die Erderwärmung die Klimakrise die
geopolitische Lage in Zukunft der Welt
aber auch hier in diesem Land nicht
extrem gefährden wird die
Klimaschutzpolitik heißt immer
Klimaschutzpolitik aber ich wiederhole
was an anderen Stellen schon gesagt
wurde das Klima braucht überhaupt gar
keinen Schutz wir schützen nicht das
Klima wenn wir Klimaschutz betreiben wir
schützen ein Leben in Sicherheit und
Freiheit und dazu ist es dringend
notwendig dass die Emission runtergehen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
das ganze ist voraussetzungsreich wir
binden den Ausstieg daran dass eine
alternative Energieversorgung da steht
es gibt verschiedene Schritte der
Überprüfung und Reserve Möglichkeiten
und natürlich ist das Gesetz nur dann
etwas wert wenn es Wirklichkeit wird das
heißt der Ausbau der Erneuerbaren muss
im Rheinischen Revier wie überall
schnell vorangehen wir brauchen die
Verbindung ans Gas bzw möglichst schnell
ans wasserstoffnetz und wir brauchen
Kraftwerke die Gas bzw Wasserstoff ready
sind und dann auch produzieren können
das ganze bedeutet dass damit sich auch
ein industrielles Projekt verbindet
diese Kraftwerke gibt es ja noch gar
nicht die müssen designt entwickelt und
gebaut werden hiermit verbinden sich
Arbeitsplätze verbindet sich ein
großvolumiger Auftrag für deutsche
Ingenieurskunst meinetwegen auch andere
ingenieurskünstler war sowie die Sachen
lese sind es gerade deutsche Unternehmen
die versuchen diese Technik nach vorne
zu bringen das was dieses Land
ökonomisch immer stark gemacht hat
nämlich im Masch auch in der
innovationstechnik stark zu sein und
damit Exportprodukte zu schaffen die
dann in der Welt verkauft werden das
braucht es eben auch in der nächsten
Zukunft also was wir hier schaffen ist
nicht nur Klimaneutralität und
Energiesicherheit sondern ein Booster
für den nächsten Schub der
Wertschöpfungskette hier in Deutschland
Arbeitsplätze und Exportmöglichkeiten
auf der Basis einer klimaneutralen
Energiewelt das ist die
industriepolitische Perspektive für
dieses Land sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren lassen Sie mich kurz zu dem
zweiten Gesetz kommen dem
energiesicherungsgesetz das jetzt in
schöner Tradition immer wieder
novelliert wird in diesem Fall geht es
darum dass eine weitere Regelung
geschaffen wird eine Rechtsgrundlage
auch für die mögliche betone mögliche
Enteignung beweglicher Güter zu diesen
Gütern gehören beispielsweise Daten die
man hat und die der energiesicherung in
Deutschland zur Verfügung gestellt
werden müssen
oder rühren bzw
anbindungspipelines die es noch gibt aus
der zerstörten Bauphase oder aus der aus
der Bauphase von nordstream 2 die aber
jetzt gebraucht werden für die Anbindung
von alternativen Kapazitäten in der
deutschen Ostsee mit diesem Gesetz mit
diesem Gesetz die ist nicht entgangen
das erstens Putin kein Gas mehr liefert
und zweitens die Röhren kaputt sind wenn
Sie jetzt noch sagen nachdem die Röhren
ein fettes 250 Meter großes Loch haben
die brauchen wir nicht dann haben sie
ihren Kopf so tief in den Sand gesteckt
dass sie noch nicht mal mehr ihre
eigenen Füße sehen ich bitte wie sie die
Nachrichtenlage zur Kenntnis zu nehmen
wenn schon die politische Lage Ihnen
immer
immer am Interesse vorbeigeht sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir brauchen
beides wir brauchen die Rechtsgrundlage
wir brauchen die Daten und wir brauchen
die Röhren und die Versorgungssicherheit
in diesem Land sicherzustellen ich danke
für die einbringungsmöglichkeit über die
Fraktion und ich bitte um die Zustimmung
danke schön
Robert Habeck hat hier die Debatte
eröffnet und auf ihn folgen würden und
direkt an der Königssee sitzt im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der zunächst
für das Jahr 2038 geplante Ausstieg aus
der Kohleverstromung in Deutschland ist
das größte Einzelprojekt für Klimaschutz
in Europa beschlossen wurde er von der
CDU geführten Bundesregierung unter
Angela Merkel nun soll der Ausstieg in
NRW noch einmal um acht Jahre auf das
Jahr 2030 vorgezogen werden und das
geschah auf Initiative der CDU-geführten
Landesregierung in NRW unter Hendrik
wüst und es ist ein wichtiger Schritt
für mehr Klimaschutz
wenn wir aber acht Jahre früher aus der
Kohle aussteigen dann müssen wir
logischerweise auch den Strukturwandel
im Rheinischen Revier um acht Jahre
vorziehen es muss damit doppelt so
schnell umgesetzt werden denn der noch
frühere Ausstieg halbiert den Zeitraum
der jetzt noch zur Verfügung steht für
das rheinische Revier wird damit der
Strukturwandel zur immensen
Herausforderung das Ziel ist ehrgeizig
in Anbetracht der Folgen des
Klimawandels ist es das richtige aber es
muss auch richtig gemacht werden richtig
gemacht werden heißt dass es eben nicht
mit der isolierten Abschaltung der
Kraftwerke getan ist Klimaschutz
Arbeitsplätze Umweltschutz und
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung müssen
zusammengedacht und verfolgt werden das
nennt man nachhaltige Politik
nachhaltige Politik darf sich nicht
allein auf die Abschaffung der
Kohleverstromung beschränken ein ganzes
System muss abgelöst und neu gestaltet
werden es ist noch sehr viel zu tun
damit der Strukturwandel nicht scheitert
hier ist vor allem die die
Bundesregierung in der Pflicht die
unvollständige Liste der Aufgaben
umfasst das folgende es geht erstens um
den Ausbau von erneuerbaren Energien und
von wasserstofffähigen Gaskraftwerken
allein in den nächsten neun Jahren
werden laut Experten an 250 Tagen
jährlich die erneuerbaren Energien nicht
ausreichen dafür muss Vorsorge getroffen
werden
es geht zweitens um die Ertüchtigung der
Infrastruktur ich nenne nur Stichworte
Verkehr Stromtrassen Gaspipelines
Wasserwirtschaft und es geht drittens um
die Transformation des regionalen
Wirtschaftssystems es muss die Schaffung
von Arbeitsplätzen beschleunigt und die
wertschöpfungskapazität bewahrt werden
14.000 kohlebeschäftigte und 93.000
Beschäftigte in der energieintensiven
Industrie insgesamt 2,5 Millionen
Menschen aus dem Rheinischen Revier
Vertrauen auf die bereits gemachten
Zusagen der Strukturwandel darf dem
Ausstieg keinesfalls hinterherhinken
deshalb muss Olaf Scholz das wogegen er
sich als Finanzminister noch gesperrt
hat jetzt auch als Kanzler endlich
liefern nämlich verlässliche und
auskömmliche Fördertöpfe für den
Strukturwandel
und nicht zuletzt geht es viertens um
die Renaturierung des tagebauumfelds und
um die Zukunft der nun vom
Braunkohleabbau verschwunden Dörfer
zusammenfassend ergibt sich daraus eins
das Gesetz darf nicht alleine stehen es
muss zwingend Teil eines Gesamtkonzepts
sein der Strukturwandel muss
beschleunigt werden die Hilfen für diese
Herkulesaufgabe müssen eher und
planbarer bereitgestellt werden ich sehe
mit Sorge auf die Energiepolitik der
ampelregierung wir wollen sie die
beschleunigte Energiewende in den Griff
bekommen wir hören zwar von ihnen die
erneuerbaren Energien müssen weiter
ausgebaut werden doch derzeit fürchten
zum Beispiel die biogaserzeuger um ihre
Existenz die von Ihnen geplante
rückwirkende Erlös Abschöpfung die auf
den Umsatz berechnet werden soll
zerstört das Vertrauen und die
Lebensgrundlage derer die auf diese
Technologie gesetzt haben wer wie sie
seine Energie und finanzpolitischen
Maßnahmen nicht im Zusammenhang denkt
macht keine gute Politik macht keine
nachhaltige Politik
ich bin außerdem besorgt weil sie die
Kernkraftwerke nur noch bis April im
streckbetrieb laufen lassen Kernkraft
und Biogas sorgen für gesicherte
Leistungen die wir derzeit noch als
Backup dringend benötigen Wind und Sonne
sind eben nicht immer verfügbar und
ausreichende Speicherkapazitäten fehlen
bisher wir werden daher ihren
Gesetzentwurf ebenso kritisch wie
konstruktiv begleiten dieses Vorhaben
muss ein Erfolg werden das Schulden sie
den Menschen im Rheinischen Revier die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion setzt sich
darum für einen soliden Strukturwandel
statt einer isolierten Abschaltung ein
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun
dr Nina Scheer das Wort Nina
scheersprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie ihrer Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag hat sich die
Ampelkoalition vorgenommen den
Kohleausstieg idealerweise auf 2030
vorzuziehen und damit verbunden ist
natürlich auch eine zügige Umsetzung und
jetzt mit dem heute in der ersten Lesung
befindlichen
kohleausstiegsbeschleunigungsgesetz
nehmen wir uns einen Teil dessen vor
indem wir das rheinische Revier
fokussieren und einen entsprechend
vorgezogenen Ausstieg damit vornehmen
wenn man sich die aktuelle Lage anschaut
es ist schon angeklungen haben wir
natürlich auch
eine Entwicklung die aus Gründen der
Energiesicherheit auch das Vorhalten von
Reserven bzw auch von Kohle Energie
temporär benötigt und deswegen möchte
ich ja noch mal betonen dass es eine
temporäre Angelegenheit ist weil in
diesen Zeit natürlich dann schon
manchmal geomt wird dass das ja alles
nicht so richtig
nicht und nagelfest sei was hier gemacht
wird doch es ist sehr wohl Unterschied
ob man hier gesetzliche
Rahmenbedingungen schafft die einen
soliden Ausstieg aus der Kohle bis 2030
dem Weg ebnet mit allem was drum da dazu
gehört oder ob man eben aus einer akuten
Notsituation heraus temporär
Hilfsmaßnahmen zugrunde liegt die eben
mögliche Ausfälle mögliche
Minderversorgung dann kompensiert das
ist ein großer Unterschied das möchte
ich hier noch mal ganz klar deutlich
machen
und insofern sind es auch klar
bezifferte kraftwerksmengen 12
Kohlekraftwerke wird eine Leistung von
knapp 7 Gigawatt zusätzlich Braunkohle
bis 30.06 23 zunächst einmal und
Steinkohle bis maximal sind März 24 sind
da adressiert bei diesem kurzfristig
herauszuholen denn Mengen ich möchte
jetzt aber noch mal kurz darauf eingehen
was wir eben auch mit den mit dem wieder
wie dieser beschleunigte Kohleausstieg
bis 2030 fürs rheinische Revier
strukturiert ist es ist so organisiert
dass hier eine Verständigung vorliegt
zwischen dem nordrhein-westfälischen
Ministerium Wirtschaft Industrie
Klimaschutz und Energie und RWE
vom 4 Oktober 22 liegt uns eine Einigung
vor und diese Einigung wird in Form
eines öffentlichen rechtlichen Vertrages
auch gesetzliche Grundlage werden und
darin enthalten ist eben unter anderem
dass die Kraftwerksblöcke Niederaußem
kneurath f die aus dem aktuellen
gesetzlichen stand ein stilllegungspfad
spätestens am 31 Dezember 38 beenden
müssten nun schon zum
31.03 30
stillgelegt werden und
vor dem Hintergrund der Krise habe ich
gerade schon erwähnt dass bestimmte
Möglichkeiten der späteren eines
stillingsfahrts 31 März 24 dann möglich
ist die Bundesregierung hat zudem eben
diese
Laufzeitverlängerung und Reserve
Optionen der gradmischung schon
genannten Form inne
es ist jetzt zusätzlich noch ständig
worden und das ist auch wichtig für die
Region vor Ort weil das auch natürlich
schon immer sich um Regionen handelt wo
er Menschenleben das möchte ich auch
noch betonen man verfügt hier über
braunkohletagebaugebiete bei den
Menschenleben wo Natur existiert auch
Windkraftanlagen ausgebaut wurden
übrigens und die jetzt noch eine
weiteren
abbaggerungen zum opferfall aber es
werden eben auch darauf hat man sich
auch verständigt Ortschaften erhalten
das ist eben auch etwas was man bei
dieser Verständigung hervorheben möchte
muss und das möchte ich auch hier kurz
noch mal erwähnt haben zudem
ist es wichtig und das müssen wir auch
mit dem
kohleausstiegsbeschleunigungsgesetz
meines Erachtens noch mal adressieren
dass in dem
Eckpunktepapier bzw der Verständigung
auch enthalten ist Anpassungen
vorzunehmen bei dem zunächst ebenfalls
enthaltenen Teil des kohleausstiegs
nämlich dem Struktur stärkungsgesetz das
ist jetzt hier nicht Bestandteil des
Gesetzes im
kohleausstiegsbeschleusungsgesetz ist
das noch nicht enthalten aber zum
kohleausstiegsgesetz gehörte immer auch
dieser zweite Teil des
strukturstärkungsgesetzes und genau da
gibt es auch schon gibt es auch schon
Verständigungen wie diese jetzt dieses
Gesetzespaket anzupassen ist an den
beschleunigten Kohleausstieg und hier
flankieren sind insbesondere zu
flankieren die investitionsgesetze für
die kohleregionen und auch das
nachhaltige Wertschöpfungsketten vor Ort
geschaffen werden und da auch zielgenau
zü Mittel bereitgestellt werden dann
auch die Beschleunigung von
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren für
zukunftsorientierte Industrien muss hier
mit einhergehen und dann aber auch ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt eine Anpassung der
flankierenden arbeitspolitischen
Maßnahmen kurz abgekürzt APG das möchten
wir auch ganz gerne adressieren auch
möglichst noch in diesem
Gesetzesverfahren in einer Form
adressieren die uns parlamentarisch
möglich ist um auch wirklich zu
gewährleisten dass diese schon
verständigten Maßnahmen wie gesagt das
ist jetzt nicht was ich mir jetzt gerade
ausgedacht habe sondern das ist schon
verständigt dass diese dann auch
wirklich zeitnah umgesetzt werden
abschließend möchte ich noch darauf
hinweisen das haben wir ja auch heute
morgen in der Debatte um die Beendigung
der Atomenergie adressiert es ist
wichtig für den Industriestandort und
auch für eine Gewährleistung von
Energiesicherheit dass wir so schnell
wie möglich umsteigen auf erneuerbare
Energien deswegen wird natürlich auch
die strukturelle Veränderung die in den
ehemaligen
kohle-regionen existieren diese diese
Veränderungen die dort vorzunehmen
müssen vorzunehmen sein werden die
müssen unter der Prämisse von
nachhaltigen möglichen nachhaltigen
energiegewinnungsmöglichkeiten laufen
damit man Zukunft Arbeit mit Zukunft
schafft nachhaltige Arbeit mit Zukunft
und das ist auch eine Antwort um damit
abzuschließen etwa auf den Inflation
reduction Act act in den USA denn wir
müssen Wertschöpfung sprechen auf Kosten
vielen Fraktionskollegen
war das für die Sozialdemokraten in
nächster Redner ist nun Steffen Portrait
er sitzt für die afd-fraktion im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren also Herr
Minister Habeck das ist schon
ungeheuerlich sie wollen jetzt also der
nordstream AG die Gas Röhren wegnehmen
ohne Grund sie sagen sind Enteignung
aber wenn wir mal gucken ins Gesetz
diese Enteignung entbehren jeder
Grundlage das sind schwammige Begriffe
die in diesem Gesetz hier drin stehen
und sie öffnen diese diese Regelung
Öffnen der Willkür Tür und Tor und da
sieht man eben Tier da wird also der
nordstream AG die Röhren weggenommen und
damit auch noch verhindert dass
eventuell hier eine Reparatur
stattfinden kann aber vielleicht ist das
ja gewollt dass also selbst die
Bundesregierung jetzt hier Hand in Hand
geht mit denjenigen die unsere
Gasversorgung bei nordstream 2
torpedieren
die Bundesregierung macht also nicht nur
die weltdümmste Energiepolitik sie macht
auch eine sehr sehr gefährliche Politik
der Zerstörung unserer Energieversorgung
nun soll die Braunkohle acht Jahre vor
dem ausgehandelten und gesetzlichen
Terminen abgeschaltet werden und das ist
eben noch dümmer als ohnehin und wir
haben auch eine Bundesregierung die die
deutschen Interessen mit Füßen tritt wie
sonst soll man es denn bezeichnen
dass die Bundesregierung die Staat
terroristischen Anschläge auf
Nordstemmen einfach hinnimmt für alle
Beobachter ist klar uns haben Verbündete
angegriffen die Ostsee wird von der NATO
ausgeleuchtet da schwimmt kein Fisch
ungesehen hindurch und so kann es nicht
anders sein als dass sie Informationen
ja bei der NATO liegen müssen aber die
werden einfach nicht abgefragt und was
macht die Bundesregierung stattdessen
sie ärgert sich dass sie das also nicht
Putin in die Schuhe schieben kann sie
lässt die Schuldigen laufen sie nimmt
den Schaden in kauf sie macht uns damit
lächerlich in dieser Welt wer vertraut
uns denn noch wer vertraut uns denn noch
Stabilität zu wenn wir hier den Schwanz
einkneifen und kuscheln und das meine
Damen und Herren ist ein Erbärmlichkeit
nicht zu überbieten
die Bundesregierung versucht nun
abzulenken sie schreibt auf ein Gesetz
Energie sicherungsgesetz drauf und in
Wirklichkeit brauchen wir dieses Gesetz
nicht die Bundesregierung hat er selbst
die Energieverknappung zu verantworten
könnte den Gashahn wieder öffnen den
Strom mit Kohle und Kernenergie fließen
lassen tut sie aber nicht sie will eben
lieber enteignen aber das ist ja das
Merkmal von links grün eher umverteilen
als Werte schaffen
die Politik der Ampel ist verlogen sie
spricht davon die Versorgungssicherheit
zu stabilisieren aber mit der
Abschaltung der Kernenergie und dem
Kohleausstieg tut sie genau das
Gegenteil sie spricht von Transparenz
aber das Wirtschaftsministerium
verweigert widerrechtlich die Einsicht
in wichtige Dokumente und Unterlagen sie
sagt dass sie die Umwelt schützen will
stellt aber überall Wind
Industrieanlagen auf und Holz dafür
Wälder ab die Kernkraftwerke sollen
abgeschaltet werden obwohl selbst die
Experten in den Ministerien davon
abgeraten haben und dass der
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck diese Fakten
verschleiert die Offenlegung verhindert
und dabei ausgerechnet dass
Umweltinformationsgesetz mit Füßen tritt
das legt die Heuchelei der
Bundesregierung so richtig offen von
Transparenz Umweltschutz und Demokratie
sprich diese Bundesregierung nur in
Wirklichkeit verschleiert sie schädigt
die Umwelt und letztlich auch die
Demokratie meine Damen und Herren im
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf will sich die
Bundesregierung die Möglichkeit der
Enteignung von beweglichen Sachen
absegnen lassen um Notmaßnahmen
durchzuführen und dazu gehören
garantiert nicht der Diebstahl der
Röhren hier von der nordstream 2 AG so
und diese Notmaßnahmen die werden gar
nicht notwendig ohne die Politik der
Bundesregierung ohne die Verachtung der
Souveränität Deutschlands hier
würde kein anderer Staat zum Beispiel
nordstream 2 angreifen und ja ohne die
Politik der
Energieverknappung gäbe es letztendlich
keine Engpässe meine Damen und Herren
kommen Sie bitte zum Bundesregierung hat
Existenzberechtigung mehr vor diesem
Hintergrund die AFD wird alles dafür tun
bald wieder eine patriotische
zukunftswandte und für das Volk da seine
Politik zu machen dafür steht die AFD
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Kollege Michael Kruse
für die fdp-frakt
Ion Michael Kruse ist der
energiepolitische Sprecher denn
Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieser
Rede Slot ist ja Fluch und Segen
zugleich man hat immer die Möglichkeit
mit ein paar Vorurteilen dem was hier
gerade so erfunden wurde aufzuräumen und
das habe ich mir heute auch als Ziel
gesetzt ich habe mir mal nachdem ich so
systematisch mir die AFD reden
angeschaut habe mich damit
auseinandergesetzt was wir uns
eigentlich alles vorgeworfen haben und
dann habe ich daneben gelegt was wir
schon alles erledigt haben und siehe da
wir haben in diesem Jahr in der
Energiepolitik und vor allem für die
Energiesicherheit in diesem Land mehr
Dinge erledigt als sie überhaupt zu
kritisieren in der Lage sind und weil
das so viel ist und weil das so viel ist
werde ich meine gesamte Redezeit darauf
verwenden Ihnen einmal zu sagen was wir
schon alles getan haben wir haben im
Gasbereich die Vorgaben der
gasspeicherfüllstände vorgenommen wir
haben den Erwerb von Gasmengen über die
TAE organisiert und damit die
speicherbefüllung auf 99,6% stand heute
vorangetrieben
99,6%. wer hätte das Gedicht da wir
haben die Sicherung glasspeicher von
russischem Einfluss durch die
treuhandverarbeitung ermöglicht wir
haben die Sicherung dass die Gasspeicher
nicht ohne Genehmigung außer Betrieb
genommen werden können wir haben die
Gasimporte erhöht aus Norwegen aus den
Niederlanden wir haben die lng-importe
in der ganzen Welt diversifiziert wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass in der Nordsee
neue Gasfelder erschlossen werden können
und ja wir haben auch im Bereich des
lng-import Kooperation mit unseren
Nachbarländern vorgenommen wir haben die
Pipelines umgerüstet wir sorgen jetzt
dafür dass auch Pipelines von Westen
nach Osten transportieren können siehe
beispielsweise Frankreich wir haben das
lng-beschleunigungsgesetz auf den Weg
gebracht und wir haben damit für einen
schnelleren Ausbau der Pipelines gesorgt
wir haben die FSA User an den Start
gebracht in Wilhelmshaven Ende 22 geht's
los die zweite FSU in Wilhelmshaven sie
merken mir gleich ich habe gar nicht
genug Zeit um das alles zu erzählen die
FSA Jugend Brunsbüttel sie wird auch
noch Ende 2022 in Betrieb gehen wir
haben eine fsiu in Lubmin wir haben eine
zweite FSI für Lubmin wir sorgen jetzt
dafür dass wir die Rohre dafür haben
damit diese fsius uns Gas liefern können
denn anders als Russland sind diejenigen
die der fsius betreiben ja willens und
in der Lage uns Gas zu liefern und wenn
sie das auch nicht wollen dann wollen
sie in Wahrheit nicht dass wir Gas in
diesem Land haben so einfach ist es wir
haben auch in Stade eine fsiu in
Anbahnung mit der Ende 2023 wir haben
den Bau von Festen lng-terminals in den
nächsten Jahren auf den Weg gebracht und
dabei sorgen wir dafür dass die nicht
nur Gas importieren können sondern dann
auch Wasserstoff ready sind zum Beispiel
für Ammoniak an Wasserstoff die Riva wir
haben mit 738 Millionen Euro in dieser
Nacht dafür gesorgt in der
Bereinigungssitzung dass wir ordentliche
Finanzierung auch für den Hafenbau und
für den kommenden Haushalt dann eben
auch für den Ausbau der
lng-infrastruktur zur Verfügung haben
wir haben die Stützung der und die
Übernahme von Juniper organisiert wir
haben Insolvenzen in diesem Bereich
verhindert wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
wir Anreizes schaffen zur
Verbrauchsminderung bei Industrie und
auch bei privaten Endverbrauchern meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das hier
ist die stolze Ergebnisliste um eine
Ampelkoalition die so viel
Energiebereich auf den Weg gebracht
haben die letzten drei Regierungen
zusammen nicht das nächste Mal wenn ich
mir Redezeit habe geht es weiter mit
Strom und Öl herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
manche reden kann man ja auch als
rittbezeichnen mir hier ecruiser hat
hier sehr schnell einmal erklärt was die
Ampelkoalition aus seiner Sicht in
dieser Legislaturperiode erreicht hat
und Ralf lenkert ist der nächste Redner
für die Linksfraktion Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch die FDP
unterstützt es ein Gesetz das notfalls
Enteignung ermöglicht wenn es die
Versorgungssicherheit mit Strom Gas und
Treibstoffen erfordert Respekt FDP
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für die Linke war
stets klar da isteinsvorsorge darf nicht
der Profitlogik unterworfen werden die
Energiewirtschaft gehört unter
gesellschaftliche Kontrolle jeden Tag an
der Tankstelle sieht man wie Konzerne
ihre Macht missbrauchen die
explodierenden Preise bei Strom Gas und
Ölproduktion wurden zu einem erheblichen
Teil der Spekulation verursacht
Shell total Eon und andere missbrauchen
ihre Marktmacht um maximal abzuzocken
das Gashändler für Europas Küsten 30
voll beladene lnc-schiffe zurückhalten
und für steigende Preise Gas künstlich
verknappen ist unerträglich der Markt
regelt eben nicht alles
jetzt in der Energiekrise ausgelöst
durch Russlands Angriffskrieg unter
Spekulanten schlägt die Koalition vor
Konzerne und Produkte zu enteignen wenn
es für die Entsorgung Energieversorgung
notwendig ist das ist richtig aber dass
die Koalition nach den Erfahrungen
dieses Jahres noch immer auf private
Konzerne beim Lebensnerv
Energieversorgung setzt ist absolut
unverständlich
die Bevölkerung kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen haben keinen Bock weiter
abgezockt zu werden die Menschen wollen
einen eigenen Abzocker wie die Linke es
seit Jahren fordert
nutzen wir Artikel 14 Absatz 2 und 3 des
Grundgesetzes von Gesellschaft wir die
Energiewirtschaft und zwar jetzt
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Klimawandel
kennt auch bei unseren aktuellen
Energieproblemen keinen halt seine
Folgen Hitze dürren Überschwemmung sind
unübersehbar die Linke bleibt dabei
Kohleausstieg bis 2030 fast würde ich
mich über den entsprechenden
Gesetzentwurf freuen die vorgeschlagene
Beschleunigung des kohleausstiegs
verringert aber leider nicht die Menge
der Kohle die verbrannt werden wird
Liebe grüne so wie es ist bleibt das
Gesetz wirkungslos da müssen sie
nachbessern notwendig wäre Deutschland
in zwei strompreiszonen in Nord- und Süd
zu trennen das würde die sektorkopplung
fördern und zu einem schnelleren
ersetzen der Kohlekraftwerke durch
erneuerbaren Strom führen den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren Stromerzeugung mit
Wasserstoff Elektrolyse und anderen
speichern zu verbinden damit wir eben
keine Kohlekraftwerke mehr als
Notreserve benötigen und wir fordern ein
anderes Energiesystem das flexible
Erzeugung mit flexiblen Verbrauch
kombiniert bezahlbaren Kosten sozial und
gerecht vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion hat nun wendberg das
Wort
moin frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Liebe Bürger und Bürger
fährt der AFD doch man muss immer den
Unterschied zwischen Enteignung und
Diebstahl erklären es wird seit
Jahrzehnten in Deutschland enteignet das
hat nichts mit Diebstahl zu tun im
Infrastrukturbau ist das ganz normal
wenn Autobahn irgendwo landen müssen und
man muss die Flächen haben dann wird das
bezahlt das ist was ganz normales denn
privates Eigentum ist ein hohes Gut es
genießt den besonderen Schutz unserer
Verfassung und dieser Schutz ist Basis
für Vertrauen und Wertschöpfung in
unserem Land und Enteignungen sind
schwere Eingriffe in dieser
Eigentumsrechte so weit zu klar und
deswegen sind sie auch nur in einem
wirklich engen verfassungsrechtlichen
Rahmen nach Artikel 14 des Grundgesetzes
überhaupt möglich und zwar mit einer
entsprechenden Entschädigung alles
andere würde das Vertrauen in unseren
Rechtsstaat gefährden Werte Damen und
Herren denn der Staat hat den Auftrag
den Eigentum das Eigentum zu schützen
aber es gibt Szenarien in denen wir das
Vertrauen in unseren Rechtsstaat nur
gewährleisten
indem wir für das Interesse aller das
Interesse einzelne zurückstellen und es
dabei wichtig dass wir dieses konkrete
Mittel auch für Krisenzeiten nutzen
können denn in so einer Krise ich glaube
das ist unbestritten befinden wir uns
jetzt und darum brauchen wir die Novelle
des energiesicherungsgesetzes dass wir
die wir gerade vorbereiten denn wir
mussten nach dem Einmarsch wir mussten
nach dem Einmarsch Russlands in die
Ukraine lernen das privat Eigentum nicht
nur geeignet ist Marktinteressen zu
befriedigen und ein Angebot für die
nachfrages sicherzustellen nein wenn es
um sicher um kritische Infrastrukturen
wie Gasspeicher Pipeline sind ähnliches
geht können die auch als Waffe
eingesetzt werden darum haben wir
reagiert im Frühjahr es wurde gerade
schon genannt wir haben die Gaben
damalige Gazprom Germania unter
gesetzlich auf gesetzlicher Grundlage
unter staatliche Kontrolle gestellt und
das war auch richtig so und das war gut
und das hat uns das beschert was wir
jetzt haben wir haben gerade die absurde
Situation dass wir so viel Gas verfügbar
haben dass der Preis in den Keller
gerauscht ist wir sind bei 19 auf dem
Spotmarkt wir sind bei Terminmärkten
sogar bei 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde und
jetzt machen wir uns auf den Weg dass
wir dafür sorgen dass die Preise auch
bei den Verbrauchern ankommen und zwar
über die Gas und strompreisbremse auch
das wurde schon gesagt und auch das ist
ein staatlicher Eingriff die
Möglichkeiten der staatlichen Eingriffe
zu Treuhand und zu enteignen die wir für
Infrastrukturen für Energieträger
geschaffen haben haben das Gestell
gesellschaftliche Vertrauen also nicht
geschwächt sondern ganz im Gegenteil sie
haben es gestärkt denn es war ein
wesentlicher Beitrag für mehr
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland
meine dam
nun zeichnen sich kritische
Infrastrukturen dadurch aus dass sie
eine besondere Bedeutung haben sonst
würden sie nicht kritisch heißen und sie
sind wichtig für die Gewährleistung des
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
Lebens in diesem Land und die von mir
gerade angesprochenen gasspeichern
Pipelines gehören dazu und dieser Krise
allemal aber es gibt auch kritische
Güter und das Güter die unerlässlich
dafür sind dass wir die Infrastruktur
überhaupt nutzen können und ich meine
Güter die zwar wichtig aber auch sehr
knapp am Markt sind und im Extremfall
auch nicht mehr zu beschaffen sind wie
zum Beispiel diese Rohre diese Rohre
müssen wir mit der Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes in irgendeiner
Weise schaffen in unseren Besitz zu
bringen damit wir damit die Sicherheit
dieses Landes gewährleisten können das
wird alles vergolten werden das wird
alles bezahlt werden und damit stärken
wir die Versorgungssicherheit in
Deutschland weiter meine Damen und
Herren
oder anders gesagt
werden sich die Union mit Strafen für
klimakleber beschäftigt kümmert sich die
Ampelkoalition um die großen
Herausforderungen in diesem Land die
Enteignung kritischer Güter ist
zugegebenerweise sehr sehr riskant und
sehr abstrakt aber es muss gemacht
werden damit wir sicherstellen können
dass wir weiterkommen in diesem Land und
dass wir die Produktion und die
einzelnen Heizungen im Land laufen
lassen können deswegen haben wir auch
frühzeitig entschieden lng-infrastruktur
an den deutschen Küsten aufzubauen und
Flüssigkeiten mit Flüssiggas beziehen zu
können Wilhelmshaven Brunsbüttel Stade
Lubmin das muss ich jetzt alles nicht
wiederholen von diesen speichern wo das
dann eingespeichert wird
vielen anderen wird es ins Netz gespeist
und wir werden damit gut durch den
Winter kommen das ist ein Erfolg dieser
Ampel
es ist aber trotzdem ein Problem dass
auch die beste Infrastruktur noch gebaut
werden muss damit die Fließbänder laufen
damit die Wohnung warm bleiben müssen
die schwimmenden Terminals mit dem
Gasnetz verbunden werden und da haben
wir die große Herausforderung denn wir
alle kennen die angespannte Situation
auf dem Weltmarkt wir sehen was in
Sachen Stahlproduktion los ist und wir
wissen wie viele Stahlrohr produzierende
Firmen ist überhaupt noch gibt in
Deutschland ist das gab es noch zwei
eine ist gerade ein Straucheln geraten
also müssen wir als Staat als ultima
ratio auch in der Lage sein privates
Eigentum zu nutzen um diese
Infrastruktur zu bauen und das
wirtschaftliche und soziale Leben in
diesem Land aufrecht erhalten
Opfer im kleinen bringen um das große
Ganze zu schützen ja Enteignungen sind
schwere Eingriffe in das Privateigentum
darum bin ich auch der Meinung dass wir
diese Eingriffe nur während Krisen
machen dürfen trotzdem ist es aber
wichtig dass wir aktuell eventuell
einzelne belasten um Schaden abzuwenden
von allen denn das ist unser Auftrag
hier im deutschen Parlament wir sind die
Vertretung aller hier in Deutschland und
das muss im Mittelpunkt stehen
vielen Dank
denkt Bert war das für die SPD-Fraktion
für die Unionsfraktion spricht nun Georg
kippels
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Minister liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mehr als Rheinländer würde an
einem 11.11 nachmittags um diese Zeit
eigentlich der Sinn lieber nach froh
sind Freude und Geselligkeit stehen das
kann er aber nicht weil wir keine
normalen Zeiten haben wir haben die
Aufgabenstellung uns mit sehr ernsten
elementar wichtigen Fragestellungen für
unser Wirtschaftssystem und auch für
unsere Gesellschaft zu beschäftigen und
deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar gerade auch
als Vertreter des rheinischen Reviers
heute zu diesem Thema hier sprechen zu
dürfen in ihren eingangsbemerkungen der
Minister haben sie die Fragestellung mit
der wir konfrontiert sind nämlich auf
der einen Seite dem klimawandelrechnung
zu tragen und auf der anderen Seite
aufgrund der Kriegslage in der Ukraine
entsprechende Stromversorgung hier vor
Ort auszubauen zu revitalisieren oder
sicherzustellen recht nüchtern und
sachlich zufrieden da ging es
grundsätzlich nichts einzuwenden aber
erst im weiteren Verlauf der Debatte ist
eigentlich deutlich geworden dass diese
Thematik in ihrer historischen
Entwicklung nämlich der Strukturwandel
eine weitere wichtige Facette dieses
gesamten Prozesses ist erinnern wir uns
doch bitte an das Jahr 2018 in dem die
kohlekommission mit der Aufgabenstellung
ins Leben gerufen worden ist den die
Energiewende zu gestalten den
Kohleausstieg als planbarer
strukturierter Prozess aufzunehmen und
im weiteren Verlauf diesen Umbau des
gesamten Wirtschaftssystems unter
Einbindung der Unternehmen und vor allen
Dingen der Mitarbeiterschaft zu
gestalten erinnern wir uns auch dass zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt noch nach diesem
sehr ausgewogenen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kompromiss ein
Zeitraum bis 2038 als angemessen
betrachtet wurden eigentlich alle
Beteiligten die 28 Akteure dieser
kohlekommission gingen davon aus dass
diese doch wirklich ausgewogenen
Betrachtungen dazu führen könnten das
mit Ablauf der Arbeit Anfang des Jahres
2020 und dann in Gesetzgebungsverfahren
im Frühsommer mit dem
kohleausstiegsgesetz und die mit dem
strukturwandelgesetz eigentlich
allgemeiner Konsens Zufriedenheit
eintreten würde das war in der Tat nicht
so die Klimadiskussion hat am Fahrt
aufgenommen das ist nachvollziehbar und
wir haben wahrscheinlich alle auch die
Beratungen jetzt in Kairo sehr
aufmerksam sehr aufmerksam verfolgt
insofern haben wir eine vollkommen
andere Ausgangslage wir haben
bedrohliche versorgungssituationen durch
den Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine so
gegenwärtigen wir müssen die allgemeine
Wirtschaftslage die Inflation und auch
Lieferketten sowie allgemeine
geopolitische Krisensituationen auf dem
Handelsmarkt
Kontrolle bekommen und gleichzeitig
müssen wir uns diese Aufgabenstellung
aus dem Jahre 2018 jetzt unter
vollkommen veränderten Bedingungen
widmen die Finanzlage ist eine andere
die Auswirkungen der corona-pandemie
sind unverändert noch vorhanden also
insofern ist es unverzichtbar dass wir
dies genauso wie das in der
Vergangenheit passiert ist ganzheitlich
betrachten insofern bin ich Frau
Kollegin Dr Scheer sehr dankbar dass sie
im Rahmen ihres Redebeitrags
wahrscheinlich in Erinnerung an die
Verhandlungen aus der letzten
Legislaturperiode um die beiden Gesetze
gesehen haben dass ich nicht auf der
einen Seite einfach nur Blöcke an oder
abschalten kann sondern dass das ein
Bestandteil unseres Gesetz
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Wirtschafts-
und personalgefüges ist und dass ich
alle die Beteiligten die darin
Verantwortung übernehmen wollen
Unternehmer KMU auch natürlich
investitionsgesellschaften aber auf der
anderen Seite eben auch der
Arbeitnehmerschaft als ausführende
Mitwirkende in diesem Prozess
sozialverträglich einbinden muss und die
Stichworte die damals im
in der kohlekommission prägend waren und
die gesamte Diskussion geleitet haben
waren eben Versorgungssicherheit
Wirtschaftlichkeit für alle Beteiligten
Sozialverträglichkeit für die
Arbeitnehmerschaft und
Umweltverträglichkeit für die
technischen Maßnahmen lassen Sie uns
deshalb hier und heute in dieser
Diskussion auch wenn der Titel den nur
den Kohleausstieg erfasst auch genau
diesen Fragestellungen sehr viel
Aufmerksamkeit widmen lassen Sie uns das
gemeinschaftlich in einem aber auch
wirklich ausgewogenen
Gesetzgebungsverfahren behandeln damit
nicht nur die Entscheidungen im Raum
stehen sondern auch diejenigen die an
diesem Prozess verantwortlich
mitwirken müssen mitgenommen werden und
erinnern wir uns vor allen Dingen
dass damalige Versprechen das aus diesem
Bericht der kohlekommission abgegeben
wurde das in diesem ganzen Prozess auch
heute unter den veränderten Bedingungen
niemand ins Berg freie fällt herzlichen
Dank und Glückauf
[Applaus]
und damit kommen wir zum letzten Redner
hier in der Debatte das ist Konrad
Stockmeier für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit diesem
Gesetzespaket ergreift die Ampel eine
weitere Maßnahme um in Zeiten des
energiekrieges und sehr hoher Inflation
das heimische Energieangebot auszuweiten
das ist von zentraler Bedeutung das
wollen und müssen wir als verlässlicher
Akteur am Strommarkt in der EU tun
und sie wissen meine Damen und Herren
dass wir Freie Demokraten uns in diesem
Zusammenhang auch bezüglich der
Kernkraftwerke mehr hätten vorstellen
können
und in diesem Zusammenhang meine Damen
und Herren liebe Wählerinnen und Wähler
möchte ich noch mal klarstellen was das
Selbstverständnis der Freien Demokraten
in Zeiten des energiekrieges ist nämlich
einerseits zielsicher pragmatisch und
schnell auf die Krise zu reagieren und
andererseits betrieben und Haushalten
eine wirklich begehbare Brücke in eine
klimaneutrale Energieversorgung zu bauen
und das erfordert auch Maßnahmen die wir
in normalen Zeiten so nicht ergriffen
hätten
und in diesem Zusammenhang muss ich
insbesondere folgende Anmerkung an dem
grünen Koalitionspartner richten
dieses Gesetzespaket umfasst auch das
lützerat der Kohle weichen wird und ich
betone an dieser Stelle leider
Mitglieder ihrer Partei haben in NRW
damit um Zustimmung geworden dass das
genau so nicht kommen wird
entweder wieder besseren Wissens was ich
unaufrichtig finde oder aus einer
Realitätsverweigerung heraus was ich in
Zeiten des Krieges unverantwortlich
finde
und dabei sage ich Ihnen in aller
Klarheit ich bitte Sie herzlich in den
weiteren in der weiteren Arbeit an der
Bewältigung der Kriegsfolgen solche
Verhaltensweisen wirklich hinter sich zu
lassen das sind wir den Menschen in
Europa in der Ukraine und in Deutschland
schuldig für Wohlstand für Frieden für
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und auch
für die Freiheit herzlichen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache in der
fraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlagen auf den Drucksachen
4.328
4.300 und
4.299 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es bei Abgeordneten werden sich
also noch einmal damit beschäftigen in
den Ausschüssen und natürlich dann auch
hier im